We're on the last section of the
last test. So this is the
home stretch.
Problem 1.
A restaurant menu lists 8
dinners and 3 desserts.
How many different
dinner-dessert combinations
are possible from this menu?
So you have 8 dinners.
And for each of them you can
have 3 different desserts.
Right?
So that's 8 times
3 combinations.
And that's 24.
And you could list them
all out, right?
For dinner 1 you could have
1, 2, 3, desserts.
For dinner 2 you can have
So you would have 3 for each of
the 8, 3 possible desserts.
So that's how you get to 24.
Problem 2.
The sum of 3x and 5 is equal to
the product of x times 1/3.
So I just read it and while
I read it I wrote it out.
The sum of 3x and 5 is equal to
the product of x and 1/3.
Which of the following
equations gives the
relationship stated in
the problem above?
Well, exactly as I wrote
it, that's choice E.
x times 1/3, that's the
same thing as 1/3 x.
So that's 1/3 x.
So that's choice E.
Problem 3.
Let me see if I can
do it right here.
A clerk accidentally threw a
valuable document into one of
90 trash cans.
All right, 1 of 90 trash cans.
Let's say there are
90 trash cans.
It is equally likely that the
document is in any one of
these 90 trash cans.
If exactly 15 of these 90 trash
cans are blue, what is
the probability that the
document will be in
a blue trash can?
Well, 15 of these 90 are blue.
So the probability it's going
to be in one of those 15 is
going to be is essentially
15/90.
How do I know that?
Well there's 100% probability
it's in 1 of the 90, right?
And so if I want to know, what
is the probability it's in one
of the blue, I take the
fraction of the
blue over the whole.
And that's the probability that
it's in one of the blue
trash cans.
And if I divide the top and the
bottom-- let's see 15 goes
into 90-- 15 goes into
30 2 times, so it
goes into 90 6 times.
So this is 1/6.
Just divide the numerator and
the denominator by 15.
And that's choice C.
Next problem.
Problem 4.
How many different integer pairs
satisfy the equation, x
over y is equal to 1/2?
So another way of writing this,
you could say that x is
equal to 1/2 y.
I just multiply both
sides by y.
Or you can multiply
both sides by 2.
And you say 2x is equal to y.
So how many integer pairs
satisfy this?
Well, any integer I've
put in here, I double
it and I get a y.
So what of the pairs?
1, 2, 2, 4, 3, 6, 4, 8, 5, 10.
They're infinite.
I can keep going.
So the answer is more than 4.
I mean, I listed more
than 4 just in the
span of about 5 seconds.
So the answer is definitely E.
There are infinite integer
pairs that
satisfy that equation.
Next problem.
Problem 5.
Let me see what they're asking
first. According to the graph
above, during which of the
following 2 month periods did
Ellen's bookstore sell the
least number of books?
So a 2 month period.
Interesting.
So let's draw the graph.
And so this is June,
July, August,
September, October, November.
And this is 10, 20, 30, 40 and
I'm going to try to draw as
best as they drew,
as best as I can.
So in June, it looks like they
sold a little under, I don't
know, 10 books.
June looks something
like that.
In July they sold a ton.
They sold 40 books,
it looks like.
July looks something
like that.
In August they sold exactly
10 books, it looks like.
I'll just eyeball it.
August. September looks like
30, or a little over 30.
September is like there.
October is like 25.
And then November is 30.
November looks about 30.
So they say, during which of the
following 2 month periods
did Ellen's bookstore sell the
least number of books?
So let's look at the choices.
Choice A is June and July.
Whoops.
So how many books did she
sell in June and July?
We can eyeball it.
Let's say that this is
7 and this is 40.
So this is going to be 47.
July and August is
this period.
So I can already tell you that
July and August is going to be
higher than June and July.
Why?
Because August is higher
than June.
August looks like 10.
This looks like 40.
So this is going to be 50.
And then if we look at August
and September and if we say
that this is 10 and that
looks like about-- I
don't know-- 30, 33.
So what's 10 plus 33?
43.
So that's our winner so far.
And then they're asking
September and October.
Let me switch colors.
September and October
would be that.
If that's 33, October
looks like about 25.
So there's a little bit
of approximation here.
So what's 33 plus 25?
That's 58 and that's actually
the most so far.
And then finally October
and November.
November looks like 30.
So what's 30 plus 25.
It's 55.
So the smallest is definitely
August and September.
Next problem.
Maybe I'll stick with
this white.
Problem 6.
OK, they drew us a line.
And they say that this is point
A, this is point B and
this is point C.
In the figure above,
AC equals 24.
And they tell us that
AB is equal to BC.
So this side, this length has
to equal that length and
combined they add up to 24.
So we know that's going
to be 12 and that's
also going to be 12.
Because they have to add up
to 24 and they're equal.
Point D, not shown, is on the
line between A and B-- so
point D is someplace here-- such
that AD is equal to DB.
So if we put D here, I'll do
it in a different color.
If this is D, they want us-- so
12 is this whole length and
they're saying AD
is equal to DB.
So what are each of these
smaller lengths
going to be, equal?
This is equal to this, so this
is going to have to be 6 and
this is going to have
to be 6, right?
Because the two sides are equal
and the two lengths are
equal and they add up to 12.
Now what are they asking?
What does DC equal?
So what is this distance?
Just to here.
From there to there.
OK.
So we'd have to go
6 to get to B.
And then we'd have to go
12 more to get to c.
6 plus 12 and that gets us 18.
So this distance is 18.
Not too bad.
This problem is that's
answer D.
Problem 7.
If n is a positive integer
then 6 times 10 to the
negative n, plus 1 times
10 to the negative
n must equal what?
So let's simplify that.
This is essentially-- I mean
they wrote it a little
complicated-- but we have six
10s to the negative n here.
And then we have
1 more, right?
I mean 6 times 10 to
the negative n.
You could rewrite this as 10 to
the negative n plus 10 to
the negative n plus 10 to the
negative n plus 10 to the
negative n-- not that I'd
recommend you to do this on
the exam-- 10 to the negative
n plus 10 to the negative n.
How many have I drawn?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Right.
That's 6 times 10 to
the negative n.
And to that we add 1 more
10 to the negative n.
So how many 10 to the negative
ns do we have?
We have 7 now.
Right?
So it's 7 times 10 to
the negative n.
And that is not a choice.
So what's another way of writing
10 to the negative n?
Well, that's the same thing
as 1 over 10 to the n.
So that's 7 times 1
over 10 to the n.
Which is, of course, equal
to 7 over 10 to the n.
And that is choice B.
Next problem.
Actually, I'll do it in the next
video because I have less
than a minute left.
I'll see--